this episode of the honeydew is brought
to you by harry's and skillshare
more on that later let's get into the do
the honeydew
with ryan zickler
welcome back to the honeydew y'all we're
over here doing it in the night pants
studios i am ryan sickler
ryan sickler on all social media ryan
website for the show the
honeydewpodcast.com
that's where you can go find everything
and anything you want to know about me
or the show
um youtube make sure you're subscribed
don't just watch if you're watching hit
that subscribe let's get those numbers
up
the community is growing incredibly
especially since june when we started
here
so thank you so much um and if you got
that extra
money and the extra time and you want an
extra episode a week
please subscribe to the patreon the
honeydew
with y'all where i'm doing the honeydew
with y'all and that community as well
has been fantastic there's some
wild wild stories uh every week
has been something else out there and i
can already tell you looking through the
emails that that's
there's no shortage of that so
uh sign up for a year you'll save over
uh a month of free episodes you'll get
and
um it's only five bucks a month so
that's that now you know i record here
at the santa monica music center
if you need musical instruments or
lessons just go to santa monica music
dot com use the code honeydew they'll
wave the registration
fee and they will give you one free
lesson when you sign up for a package
now
that's the biz right there what we do
here on this show we highlight the low
lights
we like to shed a little light on that
darkness and
you know laugh in the face of trauma uh
today my guest
returns via nashville ladies and
gentlemen
please welcome joshua everybody what's
up man
how you doing the wolf is back
[Applause]
now first moment i forgot to mention
this when i saw you but that beard is
looking
good it's nice it's fuller than i've see
i think i've seen i've never grown a
beard um
my hair you know yeah look man i'm
almost i'm 48 in march i'm almost
50 and i figured i still [ __ ] have it
yep might as well show some appreciation
to it
it's nothing i can't cut off you know
what i mean people tell me you know
i don't i [ __ ] be i don't like that
beard i'm like well i can shave this off
you're stuck with that face
forever come on you know what i was like
can i tell you something i was in you
could use that i was in columbus ohio
and this woman was in the front row and
um
she said something about um
nice chicken legs i go oh yeah i go i do
i i get
skinny legs she goes you do you have
skinny legs nice chicken legs i go yeah
i said but i could go to the gym and
bulk these up i go what are you going to
do about that face
what do you guys know about that what
are you going to do about that face
and she goes what i go i think that
stays with you and it doesn't get any
better
yeah man you know i'm with you dude but
it's funny we were just talking about
hecklers and talking to people i have a
very
i have a very distinct way of doing it
all the time
i let you hang yourself like i want you
[Music]
to get so annoying to the rest of the
audience
that i can now say whatever i want to do
and there the rest of the audience is
going to be like thank you
yeah so because if you go hard on
somebody real fast
the crowd is not gonna i'm just a big
believer and don't start none won't be
none
that's it you know i say it i just said
it on another podcast
i come in peace ready for war i'm here
to be
cool yeah if you don't want to be cool
it's that's been a big
problem for me i'm sure you and every
other comedian too but
you know interactions with people where
you know they're just giving it to you
and you're like man
you know by nature i'm a smart ass but
i'm also a professional comedian so now
you're
asking me to put down all of my [ __ ]
weapons
and take the high road and not say
anything it has
taken me decades to get
60 okay at that i it's so hard to bite
my tongue
why do you bite your tongue well it
depends on the situation
it could be my daughter's mother and i
are disagreeing and i'm just like whoo
boy let me just shut the [ __ ] up
yeah very it's so funny
just blood
i think that's the thing i learned the
most over the relationship with my wife
which is
early on when you're young if you think
she's wrong
you you know what it's my right she if
i think she's wrong she needs to know
like your egos like tell her she's wrong
yes because she needs to know it that's
why because you're right
because you're right and when you get
older you're like that's not important
that's not just i'm like i didn't even
hear what you said yeah
i'd rather you yell at me for me saying
i'm not i wasn't paying attention
and then i'll come in i swear i'll be a
much better listener yeah yeah oh
i will tell you there's beth will tell
me she was like i want to talk to you
about something but i go okay she goes
let's just wait till you get high
and i'm like why she goes well i really
want you to listen and that's actually
i'm like that's probably a smart move
because i hear things differently when
i'm high
yeah you know what i mean yeah because
my entire
like yeah that's it everything's just
like hey man it's
it's all right yeah whatever it is well
you see it for what it really is
that's what medication does it's
medication
do you uh i like how you we refer to
weed as medicaid it's medication
yeah it's a different kind of medication
i know people want to clown it whatever
but
it is absolutely i'd much rather take a
couple hits of weed
and calm the [ __ ] down about some
[ __ ] anyway
it's nonsense we're not talking about
anything real we're talking about the
color of a couch right now
yeah let me you you're upset about the
color of the couch let me go outside
smoking joint real quick and i'll tell
you what we get whatever the [ __ ] couch
you want when i come back cause i ain't
going to give a [ __ ]
that dude but that is the beauty of weed
for sure it takes away all the edges for
me meat
it takes away all the eggs i've said it
has made me a better person
a better parent a better partner it's
made me more patient all the p's
more patient it's it has really done
that and i'd rather that
than take you know some magic pill
that's not gonna really work or cause me
you know 800 other side effects right
how old were you
when you when you first smoked weight
god i was late bloomer i first tried it
at 18 years old
i was in my buddy's firebird in my
driveway my gravel driveway and uh give
me a little
description of that firebird so it's a
red firebird glad
glass tea top remember the tan interiors
on the red
you know i do and um
you know what those cars do when you
push the seat it
flopped up fast yeah really fast yeah it
came orange
it was like it was bungee core together
and it was just like nah
you know i like it for slingshots i
remember the first time it flopped up i
was like oh [ __ ] okay
yeah i better get out of the way um and
he rolled this joint and it's
it looked like i've said this before it
looked like brock's candy it just looked
like i was like what the [ __ ] is this
so i go to hit it and it just on the
inhale it breaks apart in my mouth the
whole joint is sitting on my tongue and
i'm like
he's like don't spit it out so i eat the
thing and i feel
nothing but i do get incredibly hungry
not long after
we all hit the double tee diner i tried
it again like a month later
cause i was scared of it and then i
walked up to we were all at a little
field party and uh the guys were
finishing a bowl when i went to get it
was just ashed and then i didn't do it
again until i was 21
and when i was 21 i started on the
weekends only just weekends weekends and
i didn't
i don't think i started nightly until
and i do say nightly because it was
nightly first before it became any
everything else but what does everything
else mean well
it depends if it's sunday and it's
football i'll smoke and join at 10 30 11
o'clock and watch the ravens you know
what i mean
and i don't know why i do it because the
adrenaline overrides the high every i'm
like i'm like i wha what did i just
wasted that [ __ ]
we just fumbled god damn it and then
there it all goes
like what did i do that what i do now
that's the premium [ __ ] right there do
you do you
watch do you watch the games like that
like in front of you
with your daughter does she know does
she hear marijuana no not smoke weed but
like do you get like um oh yeah
oh yeah i have a video of me she took it
it was uh this was this year
and it was a game where we i think
tucker had to hit like a 55-yard field
goal at the end in overtime or something
and she grabbed my phone and was
recording me she goes i want to record
you watching this i was like oh and then
we hit it so she's got a video of me
screaming and jumping but
yeah she's a fan she really does like
the ravens and i think the purple helped
yo but she loves lamar jackson like she
loves orlando brown jr because he's a
friend you know she loves him too
so she's all stoked about the ravens
jacob wolff
um they were so i watch
by the way is looking more and more like
you he's a handsome man
every day i don't mean honestly i don't
think he's a handsome man because he
looks like me i'm saying he's a handsome
yeah
um so jager wolf so when he was probably
like
this is 2004. so he was
seven years old and um 2004 was a
magical year for the red sox
and by the way oddly enough
i stopped watching the game any games
with intensity like i don't really
i watch them but i don't scream at tvs
anymore but like
uh the 2004's red sox i'm screaming at
the tv and he was upstairs
and he comes downstairs and i can hear
his footsteps coming down i go what's up
and he goes you're scaring me and i go
well you should go back upstairs now
because i'm [ __ ] myself it's not
going to get any better than this dude
are you kidding it's the fourth inning
like
you should get but i watch him watch now
and he
screamed the tv and yeah and i'm like oh
yeah sorry about that
i scream when it's something positive
that happens i don't yell anymore at the
fumbles and the ba i'm like oh come on
or
you know i don't get much more out of
that pocket and
after we lose in a big game like the
[ __ ] playoffs back to back years
uh three three years yeah uh
you know i don't let it get me down like
like those p i've i'm i've seriously
seen people
[ __ ] trash their tvs throw [ __ ]
through the wall
i watched a guy an eagles fan one time
take his hat and he [ __ ] threw it in
the fireplace
yeah and he's ran and this thing's over
and then he goes god damn it he goes in
there and gets
it shakes it out and puts it back on but
it's all burst up
[Laughter]
some of my favorite videos to watch
online
are sports fans burning [ __ ] or breaking
tvs
or throwing i'm like you dumb
[ __ ] you are the dumbest dummy you
just threw a table
through a tv because alabama lost like
yeah
now you got to buy another tv it makes
sense if you lost a bunch of money on it
yep okay that's all right it does make
sense
when you when especially have you been
beat bad
in a game have you ever been beat back
yeah i've been b my life has beat me bad
i have a
i ever been beat man
i have a show about it
i dedicated a studio
[Laughter]
yeah man listen i wanna because we
talked about some stuff before the show
is sort of a segway here anyway we were
talking about
being beat bad sabotage you started
telling me about
and i didn't know this i didn't know you
were battling with depression
and you started talking about your
self-realization about self-sabotaging
[ __ ] i want to talk to you about that
because that's
that's interesting to me because i you
had said
career things and i said certainly i i
mean i could probably look back and
think about something i sabotaged in my
career for sure
but i mean i didn't even know i had a
career then you know what i mean i
didn't know i just was being a comedian
i didn't know
anything about molding this into a
career and
and revenue streams and when we started
it myspace wasn't even there then
that came up and then websites and
youtubes and boom
boom trying to evolve with this [ __ ]
like what career so i still
what career what career
i got two microphones and a sign
[Laughter]
i think it depends on where where you i
think
probably where you sabotage yourself is
where you
maybe feel you don't value yourself do
you know what i mean where you don't
deserve something yeah i feel like that
a lot
still yeah for me man you know i um
i have can i ask you this is it have you
ever tried
like when you've gotten anything saying
to yourself like
i deserve this like i feel guilty about
saying that
blows my mind that i feel guilty about
saying i deserve this like why do i feel
guilty about that [ __ ] obviously
earned it like what is it
in us what's been instilled in us that
we feel guilty
for accomplishing something good
it it's not yeah it's
it's it's that you feel for me i just
feel like i don't
somehow deserve it but why yeah what is
that
and that's the thing that's how i don't
i don't know and so for like
i've i do go through dips of just
dark [ __ ] you know i think a lot of
people do
describe a dip what are we talking about
days weeks and what do you what's your
behavior
like what are you doing what are you
going through here's the deal like
i really used to identify
in a way now look don't i don't want
anyone going crazy
when i use this comparison but i
identified with brody in this way
okay brody i identify with chappelle and
that were both
great comics no
i wonder where you were
chappelle says a lot of [ __ ] i'm
thinking he just says it first
yeah but i identify you know that's how
i
uh because when i said that you kind of
you i was like where is he going
i definitely gave you a look when you
said brody i was like okay all right i
understand where i think you might be
going in that
sometimes i over overcompensate
happiness when i'm feeling my worst
right much like the person who tells
everybody how much they can fight all
the time and how tough they are they're
talking about it because they
are super insecure about how they can't
fight right or how they're weak there
and so when i'm overly happy when i
when i
i'm it just when it seems like too much
like why he's
and i'm a positive person so it's easy
for me to hide it
in there but um
i just during those times
i wake up like or you're like you're a
piece of [ __ ] like what the [ __ ] it's
just self
thoughts oh just and are you withdrawing
from people too your wife your kids
are you just sort of like being a loner
for that time period
and is that a day we're talking or is
this a
a weekly thing or what happens
it is a completely depends on
it's never just a day it's you know and
i'm lucky man i don't get it as bad as i
think some people do you just feel like
a piece of [ __ ]
but i'm always telling myself that i'm a
during that time i
can't figure out
how i'm ever gonna do anything right
like it's just like and i and if you
gave me a suggestion if i was like man
this isn't working and you gave me a
suggestion i could tell you exactly why
it wouldn't work if i was gonna be
involved
and then i'll just remind myself of all
of my failures
i'll be like why do you think this is
going to work man this has never worked
like you tried this this didn't
and i'm just constantly beating myself
down
and uh the uh
i've even when things are good
i'll come in like okay i'll give you an
example of something that's happened
recently that
you would understand okay so take a look
look at control chaos right yeah
if i am honest with myself and i had an
honest talk with an exec
and uh a person at an agency that i
trust and came to the shows
the reason that never went across the
goal line
even though i had a ton of interest
is i just never made it i pushed it up
to
the goal line and then i never made it
look good i never made it sound good i
never made the
which i could have i had the money to do
and i chose not to do that i chose not
to do that and i talked to they exactly
they were like you missed the window
when we were all there
you just never gave us what they all
asked for something
the same thing like look we need a one
sheet or whatever you just don't
we need this to look like this show us
what this is gonna look like
and as soon as they asked me to do
what i needed to do i just
didn't do it but do you think that's
sabotage or also
protecting yourself you know you're now
it's also ego in a way too where because
now someone's telling you to change the
very thing you've been doing it's so
hard like every editor i've ever worked
with this is what i say about every
editor's attitude i've ever worked with
and i love editors because they they
make the magic
but every editor i've ever worked with
gives you their cut
and then you go this is great what do
you think about just trying this this
and this and they go yeah if you want to
[ __ ] it up we can do that
like that that's every editor i've ever
worked with
attitude about their work and i'm like
man i wish i had that confidence in my
[ __ ] [ __ ] you know
but but that's but that's one of the
things that we don't have that
confidence in our [ __ ] and no
i i don't think that you think it was
then because
if i if it was one if it would have been
one isolated incident
i'd have been like all right well i but
when i look back at
the other things that i've pushed up to
the goal line and there's been a lot
dude
i've had a lot of opportunity i really
have
it's always been something that i just
didn't
follow through on or didn't go that
extra foot that i knew i had to
and i i did enough not to blame myself
when i look back at all this [ __ ] i did
enough not to blame myself
it was almost like i wanted the misery
that came
after the rejection it was almost like i
i was comfortable in that space i just
was talking to a friend about this like
i was the same way for a long time
really trying to get out of it
and i've met people especially um in our
industry like this but
there are people who absolutely thrive
and function
in chaos yeah and the moment there is
order and organization and
[ __ ] gets boring or dull they [ __ ] it up
because now shit's [ __ ] up and this is
how
i thrive with this swirling pile of [ __ ]
floating around yeah that's how i've
that's how i've
that's and you don't need to survive
that way you shouldn't survive that way
there are
you can figure out a way to thrive
without that
but it's not it's just not as it's just
boring
i i don't know it's not as entertaining
it's a [ __ ] up thing and when
something bad
happens not only am
i expecting it that's why it happened
yep not only am i expecting it but
it feels comfortable like i'm wearing
the skin i'm supposed to be wearing
like when things are going well i feel
like an imposter
and i that's really interesting i don't
i wouldn't i don't feel like an impostor
i feel like
you know i feel like i'm in in a new
place
you know what i'm saying like this [ __ ]
looks familiar but man it doesn't feel
i don't remember feeling like this you
know what i mean like good shit's
happening like
that's the thing oh yeah
yeah where's the hidden camera like but
yeah i mean dude you know
where where it started to really get
highlighted for me
highlight them low light i'm gonna man
and i'll tell you where the and also
where a lot of depression
really came in when the joshua show
ended right
and which i wanted to say that's
obviously something you pushed across
the goal line
so you did it with that yes i also
didn't do what i needed to do while on
it yeah
okay um
okay so
the josh wolfe show when it came on the
air look man when i was 14 years old
if you would ask me what's your dream i
would have said my dream is to have a
late night talk show
called the joshua show where four nights
a week
thursday friday saturday and sunday
[Laughter]
on cnt
[Laughter]
the week starts on thursday goddammit
when y'all start going out that's when
we step
up all right for those of you who stay
at home on fridays and saturdays
i got a show for you
but listen man that was the dream and
add to it
that everybody on the couch was a friend
of mine i owned right
yeah you had me on i was on with diaz
and they had to cut diaz
all they had left to him was the
introduction oh that was the whole
episode
he would say something and i'd be like
we're gonna cut that i can't [ __ ]
hear that
and he'd say something again and i'd be
like well we can't i think the one thing
i think the one thing we kept was it was
like a response he was like that's true
yeah something like that
but dude everybody on that couch was a
friend of mine or somebody who i liked
who i didn't think was getting a shot to
be on tv
i mean when i told the cmt sam tripled
he was coming on there oh man
they were like what but i was like he's
a
you know he's a friend of mine he's all
these people are friends of mine and so
that was part of the dream and then i ha
everybody i hired i knew from a past gig
or something like
so it was like and jacob worked there so
literally surrounded by friends and
family
going to work every day when that ended
it was oh i was like okay so that was my
exact dream
and it was being it was playing out
exactly the
way i wanted it to going to work with
jacob wolf
every day friends and family there
what do i want now and it was just like
straight jacob told me last night
because we were talking about it he was
like
man it was rough to watch you and i was
like what do you mean he was like it was
at least six months where you were just
hey after the show yeah after the show
that he goes it was at least six months
and he was like it was tough to watch i
said could you tell him he's like
me or the show [ __ ]
don't you know i'm bummed out about it
yo he said something to me the other day
that was so [ __ ]
he said to me i said i go listen man
we're talking about something
i go listen man it might be time for you
to grow up and he goes
coming from the dude who was a purse
filled with baby hands
and i was like yeah you're right
there's no comeback for that no
but yeah man it went s
it went and then i is when i really
started to
sabotage everything i just don't know
how to live in that that i feel like
imposter over there
it's very possible i mean i know it was
said to me when i was younger you're a
loser you'll never grow up to be [ __ ]
you'll never be any of that thing so
you know it's very possible even though
we
you and i have talked about this i and
we have the same exact feeling i
wish my um
self um god what is the word i'm looking
for esteem
my self-esteem matched my
self-confidence yeah
i'm very confident me too in my ability
to do
a task i'm giving my self-esteem
completely different thing
so and that's probably created early on
by someone [ __ ] on that and it
probably plays into life of why
we don't feel like we deserve things our
self-esteem
in situations is low and then boom you
get it and you're like
i don't know how to feel about this i
feel like an outsider i'm trying to
i'm trying to learn how to be more and
more an insider i'm trying to stay on
the yacht
yeah yeah me too i don't want to own
y'all yeah i want to yacht with y'all
you know i want to be in the club
you know what i mean i just wanna i
wanna i wanna know somebody in the club
i don't want the i don't want the money
fit boat
i just wanna come on your boat you know
yeah i i
i'm with you man i and you have got to
believe
that you deserve it you've got to
believe that you
you know you try it i mean you already
you already are aware that
i thrive in mayhem so mentally
see if you can't really go for one week
of thriving and
[ __ ] that's good and then build another
week and you know
day by day but i'd say a week for
something like that i would start with
like let me just do a week of
oh my god shit's going good and as soon
as it starts going good it does
get better it is really a lot of power
of positive thinking which just sounds
like [ __ ] but it's not
it's just hard as [ __ ] to do yeah
it because it's like you said you get
your body gets used to living this
feeling
yes yeah this weight i i really
desperately
am ready to be out of it the last like i
said last three weeks or so you've gone
to therapy right now or are you on
any medication or both medication man
yeah
it's just the medication you and i have
been talking about well i mean that's
good too
but there's other [ __ ] but do you go to
therapy uh i've done some therapy
i'm not doing it i've done some therapy
i've done some golf
i'm no [ __ ] better i mean but
i'm in nashville so i don't know anybody
there right now and so i haven't found
anybody over there
go talk to somebody man just talk to
somebody i'm talking to you man
yeah but sometimes you know it's so
funny we do these shows and we do all
this talking and
even in life sometimes some shit's just
it's literally right there in front of
your [ __ ] face
yeah but you're too busy you know trying
to find the answer all and it's just
like right
[ __ ] there and you don't even bother
to go oh my god that's [ __ ] right
there but you're 100 right though man
because
if you ask me are you good stand up
this is one of the first times in my
life and be like [ __ ] yeah
i don't have any questions like when i
get on stage it's going to be good so i
am confident
right and all that stuff but
i know i'm good because night after
night and comic after comic
we follow the best in the world at the
comedy store and i do
well i know i'm a good comic yeah i've
answered that for myself
by the way we were talking earlier about
performing down at uh
vinin all three clubs three clubs yeah
three clubs
not three of it was three clubs was it
three clubs yeah cause supposedly owned
three clubs i think that was the third
one or something like that
yeah i called it three o'clock everyone
did it up until right now it was right
there where
it was in pacquiao's gym yeah the wild
card was right there right that's right
but that room one of the best in the
city for a while
that room one of my that room the union
did you ever do where you were in town
comedy union
nah just the union was on sunset that
might have been a little before your
time
but that room and the union um
were my two favorite in town one i love
those shows where the people are on top
of you
there was that's what i like about the
belly room they're right there on you
yeah there was one night at this place
the union was done which was on uh
sunset and um it was a tiny
room and there was one night with oac
and the room was packed
and rogan was on stage and everybody
they opened all the windows and all the
doors so you could hear
[Music]
and he you know in those small packed
rooms
you crush in a way that's hard to
explain do you know what i mean like it
is
it's like hysteria because there's so
much energy just
he crushed in a way with everybody's
dude sweating because there was no ac
it was such a crazy experience it to
this day might be the my
the most memorable still set i've ever
seen anyone do
in that tiny little spot dude dublin's
was like that upstairs when it first
started
world cafe was pretty awesome back in
the day like that intimate spot
christina had tangier back christina
pizza had tangier back in the day it was
just like that
yo dane killed in a way up at that oh
yeah up at that what was it called
dublin
good god just
crossed launched them yeah well he was
already i think he was already
wasn't he all ready no that got him over
to laugh factory a lot and then boom
comedy central half hour and then away
we go
let's take a quick break and tell you
about our first sponsor harry's
too often we're choosing between quality
or a fair price with harry's
you don't have to choose they give you
award-winning blades
at factory direct prices all right they
sent
look you guys know i get stuff they send
me the samples i love harry's i've been
using harry's for a long time
all right i still shave up around this
and i use harry's my stepson took the
razor
he's got the damn thing too it's a great
razor it's weighted
it's really it's if you like to shave
it's a great razor i'm telling you you
get
it just it's very well done the kit they
send you
is so professional it comes with so much
great stuff
and and for a limited time they're
offering their starter set that's what
it's called
plus a free body wash for just three
bucks all right at harry's.com
honeydew i'm telling you harry's
delivers a close comfortable shave at a
fair price
it's only two dollars per refill you
know what uh razors cost
at the store and i tell you all the time
they lock them up they're so expensive
they're locking the razors up
harry's believes in quality so much that
they bought their own factory in germany
so they could own every step of the
manufacturing process
harry's german factory is one of the
select few manufacturers
in the world that have mastered the
technology to create a gothic arch
the gold standard for razor blade
grinding they stand behind the quality
of their blades so much that they have a
100 money back guarantee
on harrys.com for a limited time harry's
has an exclusive offer
for listeners of my show new customers
can get a hairy starter set
and a free body wash for just three
dollars
three dollars at harry's dot com slash
honeydew that's over a 16
value for three bucks here's what you
get you get a five blade razor weighted
handle you get foaming shave gel
a travel cover and a travel size body
wash it's an incredibly great deal
but act fast while supplies last go to
harrys.com
honeydew to redeem your offer our next
sponsor is skillshare
no matter what 2021 brings you can spend
it creating something meaningful with
skillshares
online classes because time is what we
make of it i'm really excited to have
skillshare on board
um honestly and i said this to them on
the call i believe that classes like
this
uh especially with your kids are better
than online schooling right now
i really think they are um you know the
class i took them i have it here on my
phone because i want to i want to get
this title right it's called kids
kitchen and
it's cooking from scratch with under
fives now
my daughter i'll be honest she's a picky
eater and i want to get introduce new
foods to her i'm always putting new
stuff in front of her but i want her to
prepare the food make the food learn how
to make it
what's in it you know hey like there's
only four ingredients in this and you
like all four of them you might not
think together you would but you do
trust me so we started taking this class
and working with food and trying to
you know open up her options for eating
and stuff so
there's so much stuff on there that you
can do by yourself
for your kids with your kids whatever
you want skillshare is an
online learning community that offers
membership with meaning okay
with so much to explore real projects to
create and the support of fellow
creative
skillshare empowers you to accomplish
real growth skillshare is
also incredibly affordable especially
when compared to pricey in-person
classes and workshops
you know if i took an in-person cooking
class it's not ten bucks
an annual subscription is less than ten
dollars a month
all right so explore your creativity at
skillshare.com
honeydew and get a free trial of premium
membership
that's skillshare.com honeydew and you
will get a free trial
of premium membership now let's get back
to the do
let's go back to you so what are you
gonna do about it what are you doing
about it well i'll tell you something
man so
here's a couple things the first thing
was me realizing it
that was the very first what made you
realize it
i honestly had taken some mushrooms
and so many people were telling me about
psychedelics and they're realizing [ __ ]
i had taken some mushrooms
and i was just i was
just going through my past and
it just kept popping up just kept
popping out what
that i'm i would the self-sabotage yeah
that i would submarine myself
and just do this in your mind rolling
roll of decks in your past
and every time you're seeing this common
thread good ones dude just like little
hip checks just to bump you off just a
little bit
and but i would always dude because i
work hard so i would always do enough
not to blame myself well i did all this
[ __ ] by myself
again i would make sure that i doing all
this by myself
so then i would be
it's usually here's how the pattern is i
would do all this [ __ ] by myself up to
95
but i would do the legwork and all that
but the five percent that i know that i
need to do for example for chaos
to make it look sound clips all the
stuff we know you need to do to make
something successful
as good as this podcast is you got to
put out nice clips you got to make it
sound good
if it's thank you ash yeah if it's got
bad audio and [ __ ] ain't nobody's
listening to it thank you logan but so
i would do enough not to blame myself
but the things that i knew that i needed
to do to push it over
i just didn't do but i wouldn't blame me
and i'd say something like well i can't
do all this [ __ ]
but you wouldn't do it because you knew
if you did it would be a good thing
and that was uncomfortable and foreign
to you i think
that whatever was in whatever's part of
me
that either thrives in the rejection
or likes that feeling of picking himself
back up because i
i do do you know what i mean well that's
what that's what i'm saying like that
rejection and that
failure and that just dump on early in
life
is what drives us i mean that's the chip
i have on my shoulder
i'll never not have a chip on my
shoulder right i'll always have a chip
on my shoulder i don't care what the
[ __ ] happens
but but from but from what and what
feeling likes like
feeling like you have to prove yourself
not feeling like
prove prove to myself i was right all
along
i wasn't a piece of [ __ ] prove to
yourself prove to myself
that i was right all along none of this
i'm doing is a [ __ ] you to anybody out
there
that has ever done anything to me what
this is a culmination of
all those people's [ __ ] used to me
collected and me processing it in a way
where i go
give them all to me it's i'm not going
to prove you wrong
i'm going to prove me right i know i'm
not what you say or think i am
i know what i am so give me all your
ammunition
cause i'm a [ __ ] make a sandwich out
of
give a [ __ ] yeah ammunition sandwich
and i'm gonna eat it and [ __ ] it out i
know
i'm right about me and that's what you
know what's crazy i carry the chip on my
shoulder i don't give a [ __ ] what
anybody says
that's what i'm saying i really don't
being [ __ ] on by your
own parents young and like abused and
thrown away
what does what corvette guy 864 has to
say about me and my lap
i don't give a [ __ ] yeah yeah i don't
give a [ __ ] yeah i agree with that
and i honestly i can't say you know my
parents
were not abusive in any way shape or
form to me like
i've really been like where was the
wrong
what happened and i honestly can't put
my finger on it
so but i do know like i said what i've
what i have been doing is uh
[Music]
you know another example is high life i
went
with a computer mic and a computer
camera for years and all the comments on
youtube and i saw him
hey man just get a better camera hey man
just get a better camera
and i just didn't do you know what i
mean
i just did it and bill would be like hey
man you need to get a better camera
and so like those little things is what
i'm starting with
i'm starting with those little things
that like i need
the way i look i need to
value myself and so those little things
that i do
knock myself down i need to value myself
look you know i haven't worked out for a
year
and that's who the [ __ ] has i know but
that's dude
i was a six day a week dude i'm i'm
punishing myself right now
and i just have to figure out why chill
out on yourself while corona punishes
the rest of the world
all right we're all almost there man
we're almost there
but i i have really in the last probably
three weeks or a month
figured so much [ __ ] out that
i feel better i feel better than i have
in a long time
in a long time that's good yeah man yeah
i feel way better and like like
the stat that my creativity is so much
higher in the last
month or two since moving to nashville
actually
but yeah man i feel good
i feel like i'm i'm figuring out
that once i got out of here out of here
i'm figuring
out that well a lot of distractions here
too
but it's the here is the wheel yeah but
what i mean is
i imagine going to nashville where you
know no one you're probably
getting to know yourself better and
you're spending uh time with your family
huge difference yeah huge difference
huge difference
i don't have this to go run and do real
quick down the street i don't have this
to go to
yeah it's been it's been a huge
difference um and that's why i think
like
not being here and not distracting
myself
with a thousand shiny things i finally
just turned around and looked at myself
and been like hey bro
you know get your [ __ ] get your [ __ ]
together you why are you still on this
wheel running so fast
you know what i mean and then you look
at it you're like oh you yeah you're
doing that to yourself bro
so and so i've how old are you now
51 i can't even and you're also a
grandfather
and four-time grandfather yeah um
and it's taking you this long it's
taking me a long time too man there's a
lot going on in life you know i think
that first
for a lot of people it's like look man
you know there's a lot of trauma
early for a lot of people and it's like
let me get through this
figure out this [ __ ] thing called
life and then i can get myself on my
feet
and figure out what the [ __ ] going on
with me and hopefully
you look at yourself and what you bring
to the [ __ ] table
you know which is very big you it's not
you're not sitting here telling me right
now well this exec
this lady over here this guy here about
you know you're sitting here taking
ownership of
but i'll tell you [ __ ] ups it's
professionally i would tell you
personally
i'm not doing that you know personally
my relationship with my wife and kids
and my family like
i'm not sabotaging myself it's only
professionally and it's interesting when
you said you're like yeah i've done that
with a lot of relationships i'm like
i mean i'd say a lot
i didn't say a lot but i've definitely
sabotaged some relationships that i look
back on i'm like oh yeah i [ __ ]
ruined that
yeah i did that because i didn't feel
worthy
i didn't feel like i deserved it i
didn't feel like
yeah you know i was right i hide behind
an excuse
or whatever it is and uh yeah certainly
have yeah
it's crazy man you know what ah it's
when you live long enough dude you said
every relationship you ever get in yeah
yeah
you just told me in there every job
[Laughter]
every lease you've been in you've
wrecked everything
[Laughter]
man what is tell me something you've
done in a relationship where you've
sabotaged
um cheated yeah that'll do it
you know being younger and and cheating
yeah
and you know it you know you just
sabotage that [ __ ]
and you know it's gonna come out you
know it's gonna you're gonna get caught
yeah yeah man you know but when you're a
young dude
uh you know i i look at uh well i
shouldn't say that because jakey is a
relationship
guy he just likes to he likes to be
with somebody i'm like you you you
better person that's cause you got love
at home yeah
you know i didn't so i was like i'm
gonna take it from you
and you can you yeah
[Laughter]
was that eye contact no you're just
scratching all right
yeah man that's how it goes yeah dude
come on man oh [ __ ]
dude i gotta tell you man you are uh
and i've told you this before but you
you know in conference you've done this
so many times and you're so good at it
but to be able to make
this podcast where people come in and
tell whatever and i've heard a bunch of
i'm like oh my god and then you'll tell
a joke i'm like
he got a joke out of that like there you
know what i mean but you do it
effortlessly without ever offending
could you say effortlessly without
being nah that's not i could use that's
not an effortlessly word that's not an
effortless word
you know what i'm saying there's a lot
of f's and r's and t's and s's
effortless they should change that word
that's a tough one to say
it's not you got to put some effort you
got an effort effortlessly
yeah now you say it a couple times
doesn't sound like a word
but you do it so effortlessly
nailed it but without ever offending
anybody
it's it's a skill man like you're really
good at it thank you man i appreciate it
i but i have fun doing this like i
[ __ ] love sitting here listening to
people talk about their [ __ ]
and yeah and really put every it puts
things into perspective like there i've
said it there are times where i'm like
what am i
complaining about over here like jesus
christ and then other times i hear
people i'm like get your [ __ ] [ __ ]
together
have you ever done something like this
have you ever been like have you ever
yawned
no i mean i've yawned during the show
for sure but not because someone's
boring not running someone's face like
this
not even moving i've been like hey you
got anything else yeah yeah
like this is gonna stop you just a pet
i can't i can't do a cat death for an
hour
you know my dad i know anybody that
knows somebody had
one of my dad's favorite things if you
were telling a story like at the dinner
table or something
and he would just look at you and go
wrap it up yeah wrap it up and i was
like got it yep good one of my uh
favorites was a buddy of mine back in
the day
uh john mcdoll and another buddy dylan
way the three of us went camping on the
beaches in mexico we drove john's old cj
down and went camping from maryland no
from here in california all right
it was the best time we had a great time
and we're we're just bonding it's the
three of us we're on the beach we
you know he's got four wheels so we're
out over where only we can get we've got
a nice fire going we're smoking some
weed and
and john's opening up and he tells the
story about
something he did where he disrespected
his mom and he said his dad took him for
a walk in the woods
and just gave it to him and he's like
you know he's getting all emotional
about and everything he's like you know
i
i really uh i really learned a lesson
and he's talking about his dad and
everything and he finally gets done he's
got this tear coming down his face and i
just go
that's the worst [ __ ] story i've ever
was just like are you oh and i that's
that
[ __ ] makes me so [ __ ] happy to take
you from here
and put you up there that fast he's
amazing it's so much fun it's fun it's
like
it's like scaring you know when someone
scares you and then you're so relieved
it's not [ __ ] real you laugh
like that kind of [ __ ] you remember you
were at brody's memorial at the comedy
store
yeah i cried the entire time yeah the
funniest thing that happened
so brody's three friends from the valley
get up and they tell all these stories
these long stories
but brody is a kid and there's three of
them so they all tell long stories
and jeff ross comes on stage right after
and goes after hearing
brody's friends talk i know why he
killed himself yeah
he drops that and you can hear the room
erupt just
blue because they need we needed it we
like you're craving that
by the way the balls the balls
to just lay that down right off the bat
when you walk out
that's another thing like i was just
like that i was
clapping because i was like oh my god
there's like two people who maybe would
have come out and said that
but to come out that it crushed i mean
those are my
favorite [ __ ] moments yeah you know
i'm
that same guy the same friend john said
to me one time like i was
i just told a story about my dad or
something a few minutes passed or
whatever we're talking and he's like hey
ryan your dad's still dead right
and it [ __ ] made me laugh i can't
tell i
i mean i can't tell you how long ago
that was it's still that your dad's
still dead
and then right like you need to
clarificate
that's the [ __ ] i love about comedy is
it's that's such a little thing you know
still dead comma right
and then did he keep going with the
story no he just dropped it he's like
that's still dead right and so sincere
that you had to
process it for a second what did you say
i just [ __ ] immediately started
laughing
i didn't say anything but i died [ __ ]
laughing that's good stuff
it's great [ __ ] like it's
i like it it's a people say dark humor i
don't think that's
in a way i guess it is but there's a
different type of morbid humor that's
not really morbid that's um
i don't know i just think that's
lightening the [ __ ] you know
yeah the moment and and goddamn is that
just funny cutting the tension
yeah it's so funny i've never laughed so
hard that i had
at my grandfather's funeral that's i was
about to say i've laughed so hard at
some funerals and you're trying not to
that's the one where you and you're
looking over your brother
just shaking they're shaking and you're
just like trying to hold it in but your
stomach's ripping off
yeah and um
my cousin was next to me but you know
and my grandfather died it was all old
people coming through for condolences
and he was insulting i don't know three
out of four of these old people to their
face
without them knowing like smiling and
saying the inside teeth used to be
whiter
yeah still straight up yeah just
killing these people and i would i could
not
stop laughing it was but you need it at
those places
because without it i do i do not
everyone finds it we do
you're just stuck in the sadness man
that's not you don't want to do that you
know you look for that
i um well my grandmother died that was a
really
[ __ ] up time for me because it's only
a few years after my father dies we're
now homeless
i'd given her mouth-to-mouth like it was
brutal we witnessed it not even when she
was dying
not no just just on tuesday like grandma
let me practice
you don't look good
hold on let me get those let me get some
chapstick on those lips it was bad yeah
you know the compressions all of it cpr
mount the mouth and and she dies and and
her one of her sisters sister carmen as
a nuns older but she was hip as [ __ ]
cool [ __ ]
and she loved church she was a nun
so she knew every prayer song all of it
and she sits right in front of us
and she can't sing for [ __ ] and she's
oh and it's me and my brothers and
cousins in a row right behind and we
i mean i couldn't like it looked listen
it looks so disrespectful so
there's six of us six of us just right
in front of your side no we're we're row
two
we let the adults go row one because we
knew we also we're not idiots
and we're like oh [ __ ] oh sit hi and
she's like huh and it is
so bad we are just looking at each other
like good god almighty
i love that man so [ __ ] bad so bad
and another thing we did we did this too
people dared us there was a couple times
at like when my father died it was
it was an excused absence from school we
were very popular because we played
every [ __ ] sport you know everyone
came to our house that kind of [ __ ]
and um so many people are
adults teachers coaches are coming over
and they don't know what to say what do
you say to three kids who just lost
their [ __ ] dad and
their mom's already gone like what the
[ __ ] do you say to these kids what
nothing i
listen i was that kid i wouldn't know
what to say to me you know
and so so many people say and they do
mean it they mean well like if there's
anything we can do so
viewing night number two we got through
night number one night number two
we're like i was like i'm gonna [ __ ]
just straight up ask somebody for money
like an absurd amount of money we're 16.
and uh we had our our soccer coach our
jv coach had come up and he's like hey
if there's anything i can do i actually
we
we could use uh you see he's like what
is it what do you need i was like
first anyway you could just give us like
a hundred grand and this dude's jaw
and we started laughing our dad's dead
in a coffin at the front of the room and
we were [ __ ]
because he was just like ah yeah
you said anything that's what you said
to me
my dad is dead and you said anything i
would have screamed that [ __ ]
scott just said he'd do anything for him
he's already took it back getting him
out of room my dad's still up there
the cough is not even closed for
christ's sake
[Music]
the next person who
who can put it together that's
that's funny though and then we came
this whole thing i put on my first album
we had a family death pole we started
having so many [ __ ] deaths
and i would we would jokingly say it to
my aunt and stuff like how you feeling
like oh my
you know i'm like good because i got you
this year you son of a [ __ ]
like they knew you know they all knew
but look at this hair bro
we're i talk keep telling my cousins
listen we're going to be on deck soon
we're going to be the ones people are
starting to bet on
you know well you know stanhope does
that death pool no i didn't know that
well stano has a death pool
a real one yeah yeah yeah yeah uh he's
been doing it for years
for who celebrities and [ __ ] yeah people
well-known people
death pool like he and it pays real
money i
forget how he does it but he's been
doing it for years let's not
implicate any kind of tax information or
anything
you know in case i don't i don't have
any idea but i know he does it with his
fans
so it but but every now and then i don't
know if he still does it
uh but i think he does but every now and
then i'll catch a tweet like who had
[Laughter]
who had screech yeah from save autobill
who had him
you're the winner yeah i love the
outpouring of you know what i mean
for screech but this dude up until a
year ago
you couldn't find a person to say a nice
time no you did not
not one person dude to say a nice thing
about this guy nobody
you know he didn't even get asked to do
the same by the bell river i know
that come all because of that terrible
porn i think
he had a porn too oh i thought he was
just like uh i thought he had
other trouble he did have all the
trouble but he also filmed the porn
oh that's right because he's got he had
a huge dong right didn't he have like a
big dick
i don't i don't think in the video you
ever saw his dick
i think people were very disappointed
first of all if you bought a screech
porn video
you should be disappointed in you yeah
you you should be disappointed in
yourself right
yeah i mean the only disappointment is
right there
you know what i'm saying you don't just
go look in the mirror and be like that
was
a really bad idea you know what i mean
like ah what was that
that's the time you could look at me
like i don't deserve no i don't deserve
to be here
because let me just say let me break it
down for you don't don't be like well
the girls were hot
but you have the internet right so there
are a lot of hot girls so the only
difference was that you wanted to see
screech [ __ ] i just can't get i'm not
i i promise you no matter how long it
takes even if it's just eight seconds
i have better things to do than see
screech's dick rest in peace
i have better [ __ ] to do well i'm gonna
tell you this i mean here's where we
differ
i'll look at it if i don't gotta pay for
it eat eight seconds or not
you know that's the kind of guy i am i'm
saying i'm not gonna go hunt it out
look for it that takes time i'm gonna
tell you something right now i'm gonna
put it in front of your face
yeah at some point i need to
i'm all excited about the schools we're
opening i just keep getting dick pics
how many times how many i know what
women feel like now i'm getting dip pick
dick pics i've got more dick pics from
men
with the black guy and i've had [ __ ]
naked pics from chick yeah well not just
him
other people too like look at this oh
man i'm like why was that a forked dick
yeah have you seen do the two dicks i
haven't seen two dicks i've seen the
head split exactly
no actual two dicks next to each other
some one person
born like that two dicks one guy who's
got like two
seven or eight inch dicks something like
that which is great he's greedy
i mean he's greedy he says [ __ ] one of
them couldn't be all little
and shriveled up like you know when the
siamese twins have two heads one's big
and one's small like where you had to
push this little one out of the way to
work like this
like he used one just a little just a
little bit this ball shriveled up
didn't make it this one just looked like
the end you tie the balloon
[Laughter]
yeah this dude's got two and he claims
that one is straight and one is gay and
i'm like nah
oh it dumb worked out no i'm sorry man
nobody's believing that
one's for [ __ ] and one's for
buttholes but uh
yeah that's it that's hard working
that's how i would do it this was just
for [ __ ]
that little shriveled up one right here
let me get up in that not like an old
jazz singer
got a trumpet
[Laughter]
two eight-inch dicks you son
it's really it's greedy i mean it is man
he should have donated
something about somebody because he's
that dick i mean two people could use
one of those dicks
i like how you designate one
for the butthole that's the way i work
it you know i don't want to spread any
[ __ ] [ __ ] to anybody literally
but this is a butthole dick all right i
i these are the kind of things that i
will put in front of you you
you know that i'm going to send you but
you sometimes will be said disturbing
[ __ ] to me
and you'll say before you click on it
what is that
and i what i really want to tell you is
if i wanted you to know what it is i
would have said this is a video of
yeah a guy [ __ ] his balls out yes
that
yeah yeah that was one of my favorites
man
that [ __ ] me up because it looked like
gravy that's what
it looked like his intestines were
coming out of his ass
like a hernia he was pushing out at
first and then i was like those are his
balls
yeah and they fell with such a lace yeah
and crazy he seemed like he was in shape
and everything else
that's the thing that got me not that
the nuts were in the balls but how they
fell out with such like it was like i've
never
considered putting my own ball bag up my
own [ __ ]
not until i saw that video i never even
did that math in my head like i wonder
if i could i've never
well i will say this my grandfather told
me once
okay he sat down in front of me
and he went whoop and i go what happened
poppin he goes i just sat on my nuts
and i go and he goes yeah i what
sat on my nuts and then i go that
happens and he goes yeah
wait till you get older and you have to
hold him in your hand so you don't poop
on him and i was like
what and he goes yeah that's a thing
so wait we're going to be sitting down
one day holding our ball bags like
because i'm gonna just throw it over my
motherboard
i'm just gonna i'm actually you know
what i mean i'm gonna put him in a
little pool of
like warm water next to me give me a
little mani-pedi while i'm taking a dump
but yeah he said you know when they
start to touch when they touch the water
you don't want to touch water you want
to pick them up
unbelievable can't wait to get old
dude the the so then when when
he's that's been in my mind so i'm not
gonna lie to you i have thought is there
gonna be a time
when my nuts will be able to reach my
[ __ ] so i have thought
that before i've never thought that guy
was young though he was not an old man
i've seen
i've seen old ball bags at the gym just
you know stuck to the bench and they're
still standing up and drying but the
skin's still stuck there
[Laughter]
he's got some gorilla glue on the end of
him i'm like what is on that ball bag
it's you know like an old dude when he
talks to you at the gym
he'll captain morgan you too yeah yeah
yeah
and it's just seeing with the hair dryer
pouring their foreskin back
i'm like nah bro you've seen the do you
see the old guys
drying their nuts with the hand dryer
under the boob
yeah so i'm saying i've seen them pull
their foreskin back the ones that aren't
circumcised and dry it off in there get
that smegma out of there
i don't i i yeah look listen
i love you i love you i want you to be
good we got to get you out of here
this was a great episode thank you for
coming in and laughing while you're in
town
man thanks for always having me i
appreciate it before we
get uh wrap this up please plug
everything
comedianjoshwolf.com um for tour dates i
will be getting out there some
uh i got a new when is this do you think
about a couple weeks okay it's still
gonna be new when it dries yeah i'll
have a new special out uh called father
time
um it's some comedy nerd [ __ ] because i
found my very first comedy cd and
i was like there's a lot of good ideas
here but i'm just different
so i rewrote all the okay all right i
rewrote all the jokes
and and i'm like oh some of these are
like
really completely different because my
brain is different you know
and so it was a really exciting like
this past weekend in salt lake city
was so exciting to run that material
because it felt new and you know that
when you're doing new material you know
how to get that energy yeah well the
entire set is new
all right so it's [ __ ] super exciting
but that's called father time
and then i do a show called high live
every monday night and ryan's been on a
bunch
um and that's on my facebook fan page
and youtube channels
and at josh wolf comedy everything else
my youtube channel has all my uh
comedy on it and some other [ __ ] because
i posted it
[Laughter]
but uh and then i gotta um after this
special drops
i have another the other hour that i was
working on before i
started to do this should be ready in
about five months all right
come back and promote it you know what
i'm gonna do all right brother thank you
very much
uh as always ryan sickler on all social
media ryan sickler.com
we'll talk to you all next week
[Music]
you